Hal Varian: Hello. I'm Hal Varian.
I'm the chief economist here at Google.
And it's my great pleasure to introduce David
Wessel.
We were just talking that -- a year ago, maybe
a little more than a year ago -- the end of
July 2008, he was visiting Google.
And we were talking about, "What are your
next plans?”
He says, "I'm going to take a six-month sabbatical
and write a book about Bear Stearns.”
And he says, "It would be kind of a nice way
to get some inside information on Wall Street
and describe the past and how we've averted
a catastrophe.”
Well, little did he know that this was, in
fact, a very good time to take the sabbatical,
because he was in the midst of battle and
could write about what was going on in a very
timely way.
The result has been this book, "In Fed We
Trust," which is being offered over there
at a discounted price.
So David is going to give us a quick synopsis
of the book, and he'll also have some time
to answer questions from the audience. David.
David Wessel: Thank you very much.
Hal is absolutely right.
I was the idiot who decided to try and write
a book about the Great Depression in 1931.
But it turned into a book about predicting
the present, and I'm taking credit for that
phrase so Hal can't take it in the future.
If you had looked back -- if you look back
three years ago, in September 2006, and I
told you that anything short of an asteroid
hitting the Earth could push us to the edge
of another Great Depression, you would have
rightly dismissed me as some kind of kook.
And, of course, there were kooks saying that
at the time.
That's one of the things.
You can always go back and find somebody who
predicted disaster.
The kind of people who predict disaster three
times a week, hoping that, just once, they'll
finally be right.
If you went back two years ago at this time
-- so that's in September 2007, you would
have said, "Well, things look a little shaky,
but the odds of repeating the Great Depression
seem somewhere around zero.
We seem to have a bit of a housing bubble
bursting.
But as Hank Paulson, who was then the Treasury
Secretary, and Ben Bernanke, who was then
the Fed Chairman told us in language they
chose deliberately, "This housing thing was
going to be contained," by which they meant
it would be bad for people who owned houses
-- most of us -- and it might be bad for
people who lended money to the people who
owned houses -- which was most of the banks.
But there was enough other good stuff going
on in the economy that it wouldn't be much
of a body blow to the economy.
After all, at the time, if you may remember,
oil prices were going up.
And oil prices were kind of an indicator that
somebody must be buying.
Somebody must have need for energy and that
suggests a growing economy.
So we assumed that somehow the Chinese would
grow and it would cushion the blow of this
housing thing.
Or businesses would somehow keep investing
outside of housing and that would help support
us.
And so, in August 2007 there were some signs
that this might be a little bit of an over-optimistic
forecast.
There were some signs that the housing virus
was passing into the banking system, but it
didn't seem like anything that ordinary economic
policy would be unable to handle.
You know, we set up the Federal Reserve to
provide a little bit more credit to the economy,
to be a lender of last resort when banks were
a little short of cash.
And so, they turned the spigot a little bit
there in 2007, and they thought, "Well, maybe
this will work out all right.”
Now, if you go back just one year from now
in the end of September 2008, you would have
discovered a nation that really was -- in
my opinion and in the opinion of people who
were trying to steer the economy -- on the
edge of the repeating the Great Depression,
something that seemed perhaps the most remote
possibility to economists seemed to be at
hand.
Not a certainty of course, but it was frighteningly
close.
When we surveyed the economists at the Wall
Street Journal, we asked them, "What are the
odds of repeating the Great Depression?”
We're talking about unemployment of 25 percent
or so.
People were telling us, "a 30 percent chance,”
or "a 35 percent chance."
Well, that's pretty big when before you thought
it was zero.
So in a sense, what I wrote about in this
book is, How did we go from the period of
time when a recession seemed possible but
unlikely to one where a depression seemed
a substantial risk?
And then, How do we find ourselves today just
a year later in an economy, which is far from
healthy, but at least appears to be growing
a little bit?
If you take the metaphor of the patient -- that
patient had a heart attack, out of intensive
care, not healthy yet, but doing a lot better
than we thought the economy we'd be doing
just six months ago.
Now, I think there are a number of things
we've learned.
We're learning a lot as we go along here.
And one of them is how ill-prepared the U.S.
Government was to fight a financial panic
like the one we just went through.
You know, the President of the United States
-- were we attacked by missiles from Iran
or North Korea, or whatever -- has the power
to push a button or make a phone call, or
whatever he does, send a Blackberry, -- I
don't actually know how it works -- go on
Google search and say "strike back." And fire
missiles back.
But the president of the United States does
not have the money.
Congress has not given him the money or the
power to deal with something like we just
went through.
It was in our system only the Federal Reserve
that had that authority.
This old institution created after the panic
of 1907 which was a panic that has many similarities
to this one, but at the time there was no
central bank.
It was a panic at which, the system was saved
by one man, J. P. Morgan, who literally sat
in his study and decided which bank would
be saved, which would be the Bear Stearns
or the AIG of his time, in order to stop the
panic.
And he called the banker in, and the banker
brought securities to his office.
And he went through them one at a time until
he felt he had enough collateral to make a
loan.
And it was after that period -- with a great
deal of political controversy and tension
between farmers and industrialists, urban
and rural interests, lenders and borrowers
-- that the Congress and Woodrow Wilson created
the Federal Reserve precisely to deal with
a panic like the one we just have been through.
It was a role for the Fed that's kind of been
forgotten -- if we think at all about the
Fed -- about an institution that just moves
interest rates.
So one of the reasons I said I have to do
this book is, I thought that -- two things.
One, that the Fed was way under-covered by
the press given its power in our society.
I mean, we send a thousand, 2000 reporters
to political conventions where nothing happens.
It's just like theater.
And you can count on the fingers of both your
hands the number of reporters in Washington
who actually cover the Fed as a full-time
beat.
And as Hal said, I thought that Bear Stearns
was the most remarkable thing that would ever
happen to a reporter my age who was covering
the Federal Reserve.
And so, it couldn't get any better than this,
which as I said, tells you a lot about my
foresight.
And the reason Bear Stearns was interesting
was, it was the first time since the Depression
that the Fed had pulled the emergency cord,
and said, "We're going to use our power given
to us by Congress, to lend to almost anybody
in circumstances we deem -- nobody has to
approve this; we at the Fed deem -- to be
unusual and exigent.
Great words of the law which are nowhere to
find.
They are whatever the Fed says they are.
And they lent money to Bear Stearns.
They actually bought assets from Bear Stearns
to subsidize its purchase by J. P. Morgan.
Even though Bear Stearns was an institution
the Fed had no responsibility for.
And they did it because Bernanke, the Chairman
-- one of Hal's students long time ago -- realized
that this was a moment where, had Bear Stearns
gone down, the ramifications would have been
enormous, and not just to people who had invested
or lent money to Bear Stearns.
So, although this is very much not a story
of one man, it is a story of a surprisingly
small number of people who were called on
to be first responders to this financial panic.
And the star of my story is Ben Bernanke,
the Chairman of the Federal Reserve.
Now, Ben Bernanke was a nice Jewish boy from
Dillon, South Carolina, notoriously smart,
the kind of kid whose SAT scores were widely
known because they were so high, a champion
speller who actually made it to the National
Championships in Spelling in Washington, but
lost on the spelling of the word "edelweiss.”
There were no movie theaters in Dillon, South
Carolina, so Ben Bernanke had never seen the
movie "Sound of Music," where the flower edelweiss
is one of the star attractions.
And he was probably going to go either to
the University of South Carolina, the state
where he grew up, or the University of North
Carolina, the University where his parents
had gone to college, but for the intervention
of one guy.
And it is, I think, one of those truly Only-in-America
stories.
There was a man in Dillon, South Carolina,
named Kenneth Manning, an African-American
eight years older than Ben Bernanke, who had
been plucked out of a lousy, segregated high
school by the United Presbyterian Church -- which
was trying to help talented black kids in
lousy high schools in the South get ahead
-- and taken eventually to Harvard.
And Ken Manning, who later turned out to be
a professor of the history of science at MIT,
thought that Ben Bernanke was the kind of
person who would benefit from a place like
Harvard and he shouldn't be going to the University
of North Carolina, as good a school as it
was.
And he went to Bernanke and talked him into
this.
And then, he went to Bernanke's parents, and
Bernanke's parents thought this was a terrible
idea.
And his mother came up with a lot of reasons
why Bernanke shouldn't have gone to Harvard,
and one of them was that she was afraid that
Bernanke would lose his Jewish identity.
And Ken Manning, this African-American, assured
Ben Bernanke's mother that there were Jews
at Harvard as well.
And in fact, making good on his promise to
Mrs. Bernanke, he took young Ben Bernanke
to High Holy Day services his first year at
Harvard.
And Bernanke told me later that one of his
mother's frustrations was, this African-American
man from Dillon, South Carolina, found the
services more meaningful than Ben Bernanke
did himself.
So he goes to Harvard, excels as a student
of economics, goes to MIT and gets a Ph.D.
in economics.
And, along the way, gets fascinated by Milton
Friedman's book on the Great Depression.
Milton Friedman and Anna Schwartz famously
wrote a book that said that the problem in
the Depression was, the Fed was too stingy
with credit.
Bernanke was taken with the thesis and their
methodology and elaborated on it.
Friedman and Schwartz thought the Fed was
too stingy with credit, so the economy didn't
do well, and banks failed because there wasn't
enough credit.
And that was a symptom not a cause.
Bernanke thought that the bank failure was
also a cause of the problem.
And so, he wrote a lot about how it was that
the banks failing made the Great Depression
even worse than it would have been otherwise.
Now, this is kind of the economic equivalent
of being a palontologist.
You study all these dinosaur bones.
It's very interesting.
And it is totally irrelevant.
Except one day, you're standing in San Francisco
and on the Berkeley Hills you see a Tyrannosaurus
Rex on the horizon.
And you're one of the few people that knows
what the hell these things eat and how to
fight them.
And so, Bernanke was accused, at the beginning
of this crisis, of seeing the world through
this lens of the Great Depression and overreacting.
That's what people thought about Bear Stearns.
They thought he had overreacted.
"He should have let Bear Stearns go, because
banks should fail and that's the way capitalism
works." But he saw it through the lens of
the Depression.
And later, I think he's been proven right.
And so, by this incredible -- really "accident"
of history -- a coincidence, we have this
guy who had been thinking about the problems
that we have just been through in historical
context in ways that most other economists
thought were largely irrelevant.
So Bernanke becomes Chairman of the Federal
Reserve at the beginning of 2006.
George Bush swears him in at the Federal Reserve
Building, and declares that his predecessor,
Alan Greenspan, was a rock star.
And Bernanke is succeeding a rock star, which
was definitely true at the time, and tells
you a little bit about how fleeting one's
reputation should be.
So one grain of salt here is that, I think
Bernanke did a pretty good job.
He's pretty close to being a hero of my story.
But we'll see in three years whether he goes
the way of Greenspan.
So that's the trouble with writing a book
in realtime, you may prejudge the verdict
of history.
Bernanke came to office, promising to follow
the policies of Alan Greenspan.
He was not going to change the direction of
the Fed.
Greenspan's policies, after all, had been
reasonably successful.
We had a long period of low inflation and
relatively low unemployment.
We had an economy which had been extraordinarily
resilient.
Think of all the things in the 90's that we
went through, and the early 2000s, that didn't
really do much harm to the economy.
We had the tech stock bubble.
It hurt out here, I know, but the rest of
the economy recovered pretty quickly.
We had a couple of wars in Iraq, spikes in
oil prices, even 9/11, which seemed the biggest
shock of my lifetime.
And even that didn't do much more than a hiccup
in the economy.
So he had every reason to believe that Greenspan
had the magic formula, and he was going to
continue it.
His difference with Greenspan was going to
be one largely of style.
Greenspan's Federal Reserve was something
like the Vatican.
He was the Pope.
He was infallible, and you don't know anybody
else's names.
And Bernanke thought, "This is not a good
way in a democracy to run a central bank.”
And so, he set out to elevate the institution
above the individuals, the committee of policymakers
above the chairman, and to say that he was
going to be so open about the way that the
Fed thought and what they were doing, that
when he gave a speech, there would be no new
information, and the markets wouldn't move.
And for his first year as Fed chairman, he
kind of pursued this thing.
He didn't try and outshout the other members
of the committee.
He worked very hard to get consensus.
It was not an autocratic central bank.
And then about the beginning of 2008, Bernanke
realized that, when things get bad, there's
a reason that committees have a chairman.
And that it was confusing to the world to
have a dozen Fed officials talking out there,
and you needed the Wall Street Journal to
tell you which two mattered and which ten
to ignore.
And so, he began to speak more loudly to dominate
the committee.
He moved very rapidly in January 2008, recognizing
that he was behind the curve to cut interest
rates by one and a half percentage points
in a period of weeks, which is something that
the Fed doesn't usually do.
And now, we see he's gone well beyond what
Greenspan ever did.
Seeing the Fed under attack, people suspicious
of the Fed, he's gone on 60 Minutes.
He's gone on PBS's Jim Lehrer Show to take
questions from people.
He's gone to the National Press Club and taken
questions from reporters.
He went to Morehouse College and took questions
from economic students and answered them on
national TV.
Because he has recognized that he now has
to defend the Federal Reserve, and people
do want to know, Why did you do what you did,
and Were you trying to save Wall Street or
were you trying to save me?
And so, he's become -- even more than Greenspan
-- associated with the Federal Reserve, one
man.
And along the way, it looks like it was a
pretty successful, subtle campaign for reelection,
which he of course won.
Obama has appointed him to a second, four-year
term. All right.
So Bear Stearns comes along, they spend $30
billion of our money, buy this crap off the
balance sheet of Bear Stearns that J.P. Morgan
Chase doesn't want to hold, and life goes
on.
And I think there, we see -- in the six months
that followed -- their failure: Paulson, Bernanke,
Geithner, the Chairman, now the president
of the New York Fed, now the Secretary of
the Treasury.
They did not use that time to figure out how
they were going to deal with this if it happened
again.
They didn't go to Congress and ask for money
or power.
They say if they'd gone, they would have been
shot down, and that was worse than not asking
at all maybe.
But also, internally, they didn't come up
with any plan, How can we create a set of
options for ourselves, so that, if we're confronted
with something like Bear Stearns again, we
don't have to spend $30 billion in order to
bribe somebody else to buy them?
So they go into this weekend, in the middle
of September 2008, unprepared.
They have the redwoods on Wall Street shaking.
Merrill Lynch is married to Bank of America.
They think that's a problem solved.
Lehman Brothers, they hope to sell to a British
bank.
They rally Wall Street at the Federal Reserve
Bank of New York Building, a very mighty fortress
that's sort of a symbol of financial.
Solid cement concrete, it's a building built
in the 20's on the replica of a Florentine
palace.
It is such a model of stability and security,
that other nations keep their gold in a vault
in the basement of the Federal Reserve on
the bedrock of Manhattan, and they did not
take out their gold even after 9/11.
It was a symbol of everything that we believed
about our economy.
Maybe we don't make things as well as the
Japanese.
Maybe we don't make them as cheaply as the
Chinese or the Indians or the Mexicans.
But the one thing America knew how to do was
run a financial system.
Not! So they bring these guys together on
Wall Street, and they basically tell them,
"Lehman Brothers needs your help.”
They get the guys to pitch in some money,
the government's willing to put some money
in too, if only they can sell this bank to
Barclays, the British bank.
The British regulators wisely decide not to
let it happen.
And they have no Plan B.
They let Lehman Brothers go bankrupt.
They say that they expect people to be upset,
but not too bad.
After all, everybody knew Lehman was in trouble.
To some extent, they've been beaten up for
saving Bear Stearns, and they talk about,
"It's time to teach Wall Street a lesson that
the government is not going to bail out every
big institution.”
They expect ripples; they get a tsunami.
And there are two things I think that they
didn't appreciate -- call it a "failure of
imagination," if you will.
That turned out to be catastrophic.
One was, we have these things called "money
market mutual funds," where people put their
money in, expect that their shares will always
be worth a dollar.
They get some interest.
The money market mutual fund takes their money
and buys IOUs from other companies, industrial
companies -- General Electric, IBM, Caterpillar,
places like that.
That's sort of what banks used to do.
Now, a lot of it goes through money market
mutual funds.
The Fed and the Treasury thought, "Well, no
money market mutual fund is stupid enough
to hold Lehman IOU's, hold Lehman paper.”
They were wrong -- a big one did.
It was unable to pay people back a dollar
for every dollar they put in.
It started a run on money market funds, people
taking their money out, just the way that
we used to have banking runs before we had
the Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation.
And that's a problem, because the industrial
economy of America relies on these funds for
their financing.
And I think what will go down in history as
one of the more successful rescues -- the
Fed and Treasury rapidly put together a system
to guarantee people's deposits in money market
mutual funds so that too many people don't
take their money out, and find a way to lend
directly to companies so that they can keep
financing, so while the housing market is
going through the floor, we can have the rest
of the economy still functioning.
And then, along comes AIG, and they say, "Oh,
my gosh.
We can't let another one go. That'll be catastrophic.”
So they find a way to save them.
And then, they're stuck with this very awkward
thing.
They told us, for the record, they couldn't
bail out Lehman Brothers, because Lehman Brothers
didn't have enough collateral to make a loan.
The Federal Reserve Law says they have to
have collateral.
They have to have a security, just the way
you pledge your house when you get a mortgage.
Lehman Brothers didn't have enough to save
them, so they let them go down.
And that story becomes the story that they
now stick with.
They don't talk about, "They were trying to
teach Wall Street a lesson.
It was all 'the law'.”
But they had kind of this awkwardness of,
So one day in this whole crisis we decided
we couldn't stretch the law.
Every other day we managed to stretch it,
but this one day, we couldn't stretch the
law.
It's kind of awkward.
We surveyed economists on Wall Street a couple
of weeks ago -- at the Wall Street Journal,
and about three dozen economists -- and we
asked them, "Do you believe the story that
Bernanke, Paulson, and Geithner didn't have
the legal power to save Lehman Brothers?”
Three to one, they said they didn't believe
it.
Basically, most people think, If there had
been a will to save Lehman, there was a way.
There wasn't a will, they didn't do it, and
the rest has become history, as they say.
So, not only was there this money market fund
problem, but this decision to let Lehman Brothers
go stunned the rest of the world.
A European central banker I know said to me
a few weeks later, "In my country, we don't
let dry cleaners fail.
It never occurred to us that the United States
Government would let Lehman Brothers fall.”
So, suddenly, you breed this enormous distrust
among financial institutions.
They're unwilling to lend even to each other,
let alone to you and me.
And that is the condition that Bernanke recognized
as risking a repeat of the Great Depression.
It was -- if you will forgive the medical
metaphor -- the patient was on the table,
and the surgeons were looking at it one organ
at a time.
There was Merrill Lynch, there was Lehman
Brothers, there was AIG, and suddenly, the
blood stopped circulating.
Credit is the lifeblood of the economy.
It stopped circulating.
There were all these banks that were collapsing
and blocking the blood from flowing.
I'll stop the metaphor there. You don't have
to worry.
And so, Bernanke set out basically to say,
"I'm going to do whatever it takes to prevent
a repeat of the Great Depression.
I am not going to let big financial institutions
go down one after another.”
He and Paulson, of course, go to Congress,
get $700 billion, and begin the process of
trying to rebuild the financial foundations
of our banking system.
And I think that we can now look back and
say that they did a lot of things.
Some of them worked and some of them didn't,
but they were not constrained by the orthodoxy
of the time, of their advisors.
They did whatever it took to try and save
us, and it's -- for the bottom line verdict,
you have to say it worked.
Things are a lot better today than they would
have been six months ago when you wouldn't
have thought six months ago. All right.
So, I think that raises one interesting question,
"If Ben Bernanke is so smart, why the heck
didn't he see this coming?”
And I think that's a good question, and I
suspect it's one that he has done a lot of
thinking about.
And I've done some talking to him about it.
One thing I think we know is that, the Fed
kept interest rates too low too long earlier
in this decade, and that produced an orgy
of speculation and borrowing.
And that was Greenspan's decision, but Bernanke
was there helping to lay the intellectual
foundation for keeping interest rates low
to prevent us from having deflation like they
had in Japan.
The second thing was that Bernanke told us
at the time that the Fed should not raise
interest rates if it saw a bubble in the financial
markets.
That that was kind of messy and foolish, and
you might not get it right.
And Greenspan agreed with that, so he didn't
do that.
But Bernanke said that, "At times when you
think there's just a bit too much borrowing
and lending going on, it's important to use
the regulatory power of the central government
of the Fed.”
And he didn't do anything to see that happen.
So the Greenspan period is one in which the
Fed does not use even the powers it's been
given by Congress to deal with mortgage lending.
And then the third thing -- and the one that
I think is most interesting and most serious
is that Greenspan sponsored a view in Washington
-- one that Bernanke didn't visibly object
to -- which was basically, "Markets generally
do a pretty good job, and financial markets
do a very good job, and there's a lot of sophisticated
investors in these markets, and they have
a lot of money at risk and they're more likely
to police the poker table than any bureaucrat
or regulator.
So the best thing we can do is let them do
their stuff, because it's in their self-interest
to make sure the system is stable." Well -- as
Greenspan confessed in a hearing before Henry
Waxman's committee -- that worldview was wrong.
And as a result, the poker table tipped over,
and it nearly took all of us with it.
And that, I think, is the biggest sin of the
Greenspan era -- and one for which Bernanke
was present.
Now, he's tried to redress that.
The Fed has passed some rules to make sure
that there will -- nobody's making mortgages
today that nobody wants to make in the first
place.
They've done a great job of closing the barn
door after the horses have fled.
But I think that the question going forward
is whether they've learned enough lessons
to help come up with some way to manage modern
democratic financial capitalism in a way that
we get the benefits of all this financial
innovation without having to go for a ride
that takes the economy off the cliff.
So, let me stop where we are now and then
we can go in any number of directions depending
on what your questions are.
So Bernanke. How's he doing?
Well, he got himself reappointed, which is
I think, something that makes him quite proud
that a democratic president who had other
options chose to replace a central banker
who was appointed by a Republican.
It's a kind of a reward for having done a
reasonably good job under fire.
I think Obama re-appointed him for a couple
of reasons.
One is that it was not convenient to change
drivers at a time when the road is still so
bumpy and windy.
And secondly, Obama is trying to declare victory
against the recession.
And it's a little hard to declare victory
and then fire the general.
Second thing he has to do is, figure out,
"Okay. I open the spigot.
I put all this money into the economy.
Now, it's a lot of money.
When Ben Bernanke became Chairman of the Federal
Reserve in 2006, the Fed had $800 billion
of loans and securities on its books.
Today, they have $2 trillion worth.
And they did that without any okay of Congress
or the President or the Secretary of the Treasury.
They did that under the power the law gives
them all on their own.
And Bernanke has to decide, When do I take
that back?
When do I raise interest rates?
When do I pull some of this credit out?
Do it too soon? We got another recession.
Do it too late? And he gets more inflation
than he thinks is welcome.
It takes a great deal of luck and technical
skill.
But it also -- and I think this is his third
challenge -- takes an enormous amount of political
fortitude.
Because one thing that has happened in this
crisis is, the Fed has exposed how much power
it actually has.
It exposes itself as almost a fourth branch
of government.
The ability to create all this money and decide
which institutions live and which ones die,
and that has created a great deal of suspicion
of the Fed.
Some of this is deeply rooted in American
history.
There was a fight between Alexander Hamilton
and Thomas Jefferson over whether we ought
to have a central bank.
Hamilton said 'yes,' Jefferson said 'no.'
There's always been a great deal of suspicion
in the United States about concentrated financial
power, even when it's kind of half in the
government, the way the Fed is.
And the second thing is that, this has angered
people, this episode.
People in America think Wall Street got bailed
out and they didn't.
So Ben Bernanke went on 60 minutes to tell
people, "I didn't want to bail out Wall Street.
I wanted to bail out Main Street.
But the only way to bail out Main Street was
to bail out Wall Street.”
It's kind of a hard argument to make.
Or as Barney Frank -- who's the wonderfully
clever Chairman of the House Financial Services
Committee, who is the source of almost all
great one-liners on everything economic said
at a hearing the other day -- he said, "The
problem we have here is that it's really hard
for a politician to get reelected with a bumper
sticker that says, It could have been worse.”
And that's basically where we are right now.
Ben Bernanke in my book is a hero, because
it could have been worse.
It's just kind of hard to convince people
of that.
Thank you very much.
>> [Clapping]
>> [pause]
David Wessel: There's one right behind you.
Good. Please.
Q So, as you rightly said, one of the criticisms
of the Greenspan Fed was keeping interest
rates low for so long, and perhaps Bernanke
Fed is making the same mistake or perhaps
not.
We don't know until hindsight.
David Wessel: Right.
Q Do you ever see a Fed chairman like, you
know, Volcker, coming back, who is much more
aggressive on pricking bubbles in their infancy?
David Wessel: Well, I don't think Volcker
is a good example of someone who pricks a
bubble.
Paul Volcker, who was the Chairman of the
Federal Reserve in the 1980s -- early 1980s
-- took over at a time when we had very high
inflation in the United States.
And he had the guts to say, "I'm going to
raise interest rates so high that the economy
will go into such a deep recession that there's
no way that we can have inflation.”
And I think he set an example for central
bankers and both Greenspan and Bernanke have
benefited by the view that, as painful as
that was, that was probably the right thing
and we have a stronger economy as a result.
So Bernanke says he's determined not to let
inflation get out of hand.
Now, to be sure, inflation is not a problem
now.
It's really hard to get a good inflation going
when you have ten percent unemployment and
more unused capacity in American factories
than we've had in decades.
The question is whether he has created so
much money that he won't pull it out of the
system in time to avoid the inflation.
I can tell you that he says he will and I
believe that he intends to, but will he be
able to do it or not is not a question I can
answer.
And the people who look at history -- and
the wonderful thing about economics is you
can find an historical example for any case
you want to make.
The people who look at history say that, When
countries get into trouble and they borrow
lots of money, they tend to end up creating
inflation to get out of it, because it's easier
to pay back your debts with cheaper dollars.
But I don't know that that -- and that's true.
That's a definite effect.
But I don't know -- and if you say the opposite,
and you say, "Well, this is different.
This is the United States of America, and
things are weirder here.
We have some -- we have a currency that no
one else can match.
And we have all sorts of things.”
So you say, "Well, this time is going to be
different.”
And then, cynical reporters like me say, "We've
heard that before.
It's always going to be different.”
So is it a risk? Yes.
Do I know what's going to happen? No.
Q So you said that Greenspan's greatest sin
was his sort of faith in the free market,
right? But I think it's not really very controversial
to say that his greatest sin was the low interest
rates.
David Wessel: Right. Well, they're related.
Look, let me give you the answer this way.
I think it's very easy to say in hindsight
that the Fed kept interest rates too low too
long, but that was only obvious in hindsight.
Where were we when he was doing this? We were
-- he thought and Bernanke thought -- at
risk of having something like Japan, where
you have this deflation where prices fall
and people don't spend, and you end up in
a kind of a downward spiral.
And their reading of the economy and of economics
was that at times like that you cut interest
rates low and you let them stay low until
the economy gets going again.
And it wasn't so obvious at the time that
that was the wrong decision.
I think the question about relying on the
self-interest of markets to regulate themselves
was more evident at the time that that was
a mistake.
There was one big mistake which was, people
thought that if -- you and Greenspan had a
very good way of talking about this -- if
you made a lot of loans and turned them into
securities and sold those securities to other
people, you spread the risks throughout the
system and that that would make for a more
stable economy.
His metaphor was it was like the electronics
on an airplane.
On a sophisticated airplane, the electronics
were always adjusting so the ride could be
smoother.
The financial system was these electronics,
and it was absorbing a lot of the volatility
in the economy so the economy -- the airplane
-- could fly more smoothly.
That was widely held. It turned out to be
wrong.
But the second thing -- and this is where
there were lots of objections -- was this
view that, when in doubt, don't regulate.
And that was something that was challenged
at the time, but he had so much intellectual
clout.
He had so convinced people that he knew more
than they did that they listened to him.
And he was part of a groupthink in Washington
that led that basically we'll have a better
economy the fewer financial regulations we
have.
And so, the reason I say that I think that
was the bigger sin was because, I think that
was more evident at the time.
Interest rates being too low for too long
is only really clear to me in hindsight.
Q Another question if I may?
David Wessel: Sure.
Q Yeah. So we therefore created basically
-- or continue to create -- moral hazard,
right?
And so, instead of asking ourselves, How do
we convince basically these people to say,
"Okay, take our money to bail out these players
in the financial system when they fail.”
Shouldn't we be asking, Why don't they have
the incentive?
Why doesn't it come back to them?
David Wessel: Yes, absolutely.
Q What's wrong with the system?
And aren't a lot of the things that Bernanke
and Greenspan did -- aren't they perpetuating
the moral hazard?
David Wessel: Yes. So there are two parts
to what you said.
One is, there's one easy part and one hard
part.
The easy part is,
"Okay. So it should have been obvious and
now we know.”
If you tell people, If you make a mortgage
to somebody, and then you take that mortgage
and sell it to somebody else, and if the homeowner
doesn't pay the loan, the somebody else gets
stuck with the losses, that you don't have
much incentive to be very careful about who
you lend to.
Even less incentive if you're making a lot
of money by moving these mortgages.
So that business will probably come to an
end now.
And there are proposals -- which the administration
and the Fed is in favor of -- which says,
If you make a mortgage to somebody, you've
got to hold a piece of it.
So if they don't pay back the mortgage, you're
on the hook too, not just the poor schnook
who bought the loan.
So that's the easy part. We have had a system
that.
Q But that doesn't eliminate the poor schnooks
buying those loans though.
Shouldn't they watch out too?
David Wessel: Yes, they should. Right?
But, that's one of the things that's kind
of frustrating about this.
They were sophisticated people.
The people at Bear Stearns had a lot of money
in their company, yet they did things that
were risky.
But I think the bigger moral hazard question
is one you alluded to.
"Moral hazard" means that if you give somebody
insurance and say, "If you do something stupid,
we'll cover your losses.”
You kind of don't have much reason to be careful.
And so, we have set up a situation where if
you lend money to a big financial institution
on Wall Street, if it's big enough, you can
be sure that, as a result of this crisis,
the Fed and the Treasury will make you whole
if they go under.
Which will lead to you lend them more money
at cheaper rates than is wise and will create
an incentive for them to take bigger risks
and put us through this wringer again.
And that is a huge problem that they're wrestling
with now in Washington how to solve.
It's often called "The too-big-to-fail problem.”
Now, one answer -- George Schultz, who's now
at Stanford says,
"Too big to fail? Means you're too big.”
And that we ought not to have so many big
institutions.
The current thinking at the Fed and the Treasury
is that that's just not possible, that there
are advantages to scale, and there are particularly
lots of big banks around the world.
We have a list in the Wall Street Journal
today of the ten biggest banks and two of
them are American, eight are foreign.
So if we bust up those two, we still have
a lot of big foreign banks and they could
do the same thing to us that Lehman Brothers
just did to us.
So they're wrestling with ways in which you
create fewer incentives to get big, and you
basically tax them if they're relying on this
government insurance.
So if you read the stories that are coming
out of the G-20 meeting in Pittsburg this
week, you'll see that Tim Geithner, the Treasury
Secretary, is on a kind of campaign to get
banks to hold more capital.
What that means is that, These big institutions
-- if they're putting the whole system at
risk -- should be forced to have bigger capital
cushions, so if they have losses, they can
absorb more of the losses themselves.
The bigger the capital cushion, the less leverage
they have, the less borrowing ability, the
less profitable they will be.
And so, they're trying to set up a system
where, If you are too big to fail, you have
to pay some penalty and take some safeguards
in order to make it less likely that we'll
run through this thing.
But it's very difficult because, no matter
what the Treasury, the Fed, and the President
say, no one's going to believe them when they
say, "We're not going to save a big financial
institution.”
We just proved that. If things are bad enough,
we'll save them.
Q And you can't really legislate success,
right?
You can't say --
David Wessel: You cannot legislate success.
Q Can you talk a little bit about where the
AIG money went?
David Wessel: Let's bracket that and let some
other people -- if we run out of questions,
I'll answer that.
Q Sort of a segway from the moral hazard question.
Some of these CDOs, they're actually.
You know, people didn't think they were taking
risks, because they were all rated as good
as U.S.
Treasuries by the rating agencies.
And there was at least some recent reports
that I saw that there might be some corruption
involved in the sense that they actually give
good ratings because they thought they wouldn't
get more business if they give bad ratings
to these things.
I mean, how does the regulatory agencies,
the laws, actually?
David Wessel: Right. That's a good question.
All right. So one of the things that's kind
of the most upsetting about this whole episode
is, How many institutions and checks on the
financial system failed here.
I mean, just think of the litany.
So there were these bank risk management committees
that didn't know the risks that their banks
were taking.
There were the credit rating agencies, as
you say, which certified things as being triple
A, that was supposed to mean that there was
very little chance of default, which proved
to be wrong.
They had an incentive, you're right.
They were paid by issuers, and that seems
like somewhat of a corrupt system.
They were the people who made the mortgages
that we talked about earlier.
They were the people who took the mortgages,
hoping that they would never have to worry
because if house prices go up, you can always
refinance.
And there was the regulators that were kind
of blind to the fact that -- looking at banks
one at a time didn't tell you about how much
problems at Bank A could affect Bank C, D,
and E, and how the problems at Bank E could
affect F, G, and H.
And so, they didn't look at the thing systemically.
And I think there was also -- to be quite
candid -- a failure on our part in the press
that we didn't listen enough to the people
who were trying to point this out.
And when we did write about problems, we didn't
do it in a way that had an impact.
And that's a failure on our part.
So, but one of the things that -- so, and
we are now addressing those serially.
And people should be more skeptical about
rating agencies and I think they will be in
the future.
The government did things to set up the rating
agencies as authorities and the government
is now going to undo that.
But there is -- part of the thing that you
said, which reminds you that This is kind
of an unusual event, and people do not get
prepared for very, very improbable, unusual
events.
People got mortgages, these mortgages were
put into a pool, they sliced them into ten
pieces, and they said that the first piece
you got hit by the first people who don't
pay their mortgages, and if there's not enough
money there, then the second piece will get
hit, all the way through to the tenth piece.
And the tenth piece looked relatively safe.
It probably wasn't triple A, but there was
good reason to believe it was safe.
After all, there were nine other slices that
were going to have to get whacked before you
did.
But housing prices fell so much that the tenth
piece got whacked.
And there, I think, is where we learned just
how much of our financial system was built
on the jello of an assumption that housing
prices would never fall across the board in
the United States.
And that really was a failure of imagination.
People just did not think that could happen.
They were taking greater risks than they realized,
and we're paying the price now.
Q Yeah.
I'm curious what your thoughts around just
kind of the government's decision to let Lehman
fail.
And if it was based on kind of Paulson's overplaying
his hand that the government wouldn't backstop
a deal with say, Barclays, and what not.
And then, the ultimate kind of hypocrisy if
not, the way that it looks in terms of conflicts
of interest having him being the former president
CEO of Goldman Sachs and backing up AIG and
the whole relationship there.
What are your thoughts on that?
David Wessel: So it's a good question and
you hear that a lot.
Just so people understand where this is coming
from.
So Paulson is a former CEO of Goldman Sachs
and he's the Treasury Secretary.
And there's a long history of people going
from Goldman Sachs to positions in Washington.
We sometimes call them "Government Sachs"
for that reason.
And it is clear that Paulson is kind of an
impulsive guy who has a visceral dislike for
both the people at Bear Stearns and the people
at Lehman Brothers and realizes like,
"Oh, my gosh. This could really be bad. Goldman
Sachs could be next.”
And that helps motivate him.
So I think in terms if -- So if you're asking
me, "Did that have any influence on him?"
the answer is, "Yes.”
Are you asking me, "Was Hank Paulson a card-carrying
member of the Wall Street establishment, who
believed that, 'Investment banks do more good
than harm'?”
The answer to that is, "Yes.”
But where I think people are just a little
too conspiratorial to me is "That he was doing
all this because it was going to line his
own pocket or take care of Goldman Sachs,"
and I honestly don't believe that's the case.
I know it doesn't sound like the cynical reporter,
but I don't think that that's fair to him.
I think he really was trying to save the system.
But there is a big question about Goldman
Sachs, which basically goes like this, "They
always seem to be on the winning side of this
thing.
So, are they smart or do they cheat?”
And honest to God, I don't know the answer.
And it's one of the reasons I'm hoping that
this commission that was set up that Phil
Angelides chairs, the Treasurer of California,
will make that one of their questions.
Because it would be good to learn -- if they
were so smart -- what we can learn from that.
And they are pretty good at managing risks,
but if they are taking advantage of their
strength in order to do end-runs or getting
inside information from the government about
what the government's going to do, then that's
obviously not fair and something needs to
be done about it.
I think the decision on Lehman -- I think
it's a muddle.
We're never really going to know what motivated
them. I think -- and they've changed their
story over time, as I say.
They now build it all on this legal thing.
But I think that they would have preferred
to sell it to Barclay's.
I think Paulson was trying to do the tough-guy
thing to Wall Street.
And one of Paulson's failures I think is that
he was a dealmaker.
So he would say things in the process of making
a deal that, you know, when the deal's done
it doesn't really matter that I kind of exaggerated.
But when you're running a government policy,
people tend to believe what you say.
And they kind of think that you're enunciating
a principle that will apply tomorrow, the
day after, the day after that.
So he says things, "I am not going to buy
stock in the banks.
We're only going to use this $700 billion
to buy assets.”
And then, Congress has barely passed the law
and he says, "We got to buy stock in the banks.”
And then he says, "Why are people so confused?”
And I've talked to him about this.
He honestly thinks if he stood here before
you and he's writing a book -- we'll see if
he can pull it off -- if he could explain
to you all the things that were going through
his mind when he said something was not true,
you would be sympathetic and understand that
it's okay that he didn't say what he was really
thinking.
The mall line to that is, "Well, what you
say -- it's what people hear that matters.
And people heard you say one thing and not
another.
They're confused.
And so, it makes them suspicious of everything
else.”
Q It was my understanding that one of the
reasons for the past crisis was that the banks
were over-leveraged?
David Wessel: Correct.
Q That they essentially lent money to each
other, borrowed from each other, the monies
that they kind of printed themselves that
were not issued by the Fed.
It was just IOUs.
So the question is, Is the economy leveraged
now, where we still have more this, you know,
funny money circulating in the economy and
the second crisis awaits?
David Wessel: Well, I hope the second crisis
doesn't await, but there's always a possibility.
Look I don't -- it is true that the banking
system and the whole U.S. economy was leveraged
to a degree that now seems imprudent.
'Leveraged' meaning that they -- you have
ten dollars worth of capital.
You borrow $90 billion worth of capital, and
you invest it in something.
And then if it goes up, you make a huge return,
because you have only a little bit of capital
invested.
But if it goes down, you're out of business.
And I don't think it's right to say that was
funny money.
In fact, the problem was it wasn't so funny.
There were people who had lent them that money.
And those people were kind of upset when it
looked like the money wouldn't get paid back.
So if you were a bondholder of Washington
Mutual up in Washington state, you didn't
get all your money back.
Or if you were a preferred shareholder of
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac -- the government
sponsored mortgage entities -- you didn't
get all your money back.
So it was not funny money.
Now, the question is, So we have too much
leverage.
We are in the process of, as they say, "de-leveraging.”
And what that means is, people are going to
have to live a little bit closer within their
means.
And what we see, if you look at the data -- what
you see is businesses, both financial and
nonfinancial, and households in particular,
are paying back their debt.
They're saving more, and the government has
compensated for that by borrowing tons.
And this makes a lot of sense because, if
everybody tried to pay down their debts all
at once and stop spending money, we'd have
an even worse recession than we have now.
The question is, Will the government be able
to restrain its borrowing and pay that back,
or are we going to end up with some other
kind of bubble that comes from having too
much government debt and that borrows too
much?
Is that responsive?
Q Not really, but go ahead.
Q yeah, well, essentially the question was
If the economist have a formulas that can
tell them if the system is over-leveraged?
David Wessel: The answer is, "no."
Q Okay
>> [laughter]
David Wessel: -- and if they did, you shouldn't
believe it.
Are there any questions from online you want
to ask?
Q Sure.
I think we might have touched on this briefly,
but a popular question was, "Why does the
Fed continue to allow Goldman access to its
discount window and other credit facilities
at such low rates?
They're clearly very profitable and already
rarely act as a lender, especially for small
to mid-size businesses.”
David Wessel: Right. All right.
So what happened in this crisis was that,
There were things that were banks -- that
the Fed lent to traditionally, and there were
things that were not banks -- that the Fed
lent to untraditionally.
And then, things that were not banks -- magic
formula, they call themselves 'banks,' and
now they can borrow from the Fed.
And Goldman is one of them.
I suspect that Goldman is actually not borrowing
very much from the Fed right now.
But it's one of these things where it's kind
of like, In order to save the system, you
have to save the banks on Wall Street.
And as I said, as Bernanke said, "You have
to save Wall Street in order to save Main
Street.”
And if you save Wall Street, people who are
big players on Wall Street are going to get
bailed out.
And the question about AIG earlier is related
to that.
Because, Why did they have to save AIG?
Why did they decide they had to save AIG?
Because AIG had deals with almost everybody
in the world.
And they were afraid that if AIG went under
in a messy way -- the same way Lehman had
gone under in a messy way -- that the system
would stop functioning.
So they paid off all of AIG's creditors at
a hundred cents on the dollar.
And among those creditors was Goldman Sachs
and a lot of other banks, a lot of them overseas.
And that leads people to say like, "Well,
what kind of a game is this, right?”
You work for Chrysler and your contract is
shredded, because the company goes bankrupt
and you have to take lower wages or less health
care, but you're smart enough to make bets
with some big financial institution that the
federal government has determined is -- we
are unable to let go, and you get paid off
a hundred cents on the dollar.
And there's a lot of logic to that thing.
So one of the things that's going on now -- one
of the things I find most frustrating as a
citizen is that, Bernanke and Obama and Geithner
have gone to Congress and said, "We don't
want to be in this position again.
If there's another Lehman or AIG that goes,
we want to have a choice between bankruptcy
-- which we think is too messy, and too dangerous
-- and bailout, which you don't like.
So give us some third way.
The same way that the FDIC can go in and take
care of a failing bank.
Let us decide who gets paid back or who doesn't
get paid back.
Let us do the sort of rough justice thing.”
And Congress has refused to give them that
power.
Not because they're against it, but because
Congress can't seem to get anything done these
days.
And so, one of the things that's most frightening
is that Bernanke and Geithner and Obama have
no more authority to deal with a crisis like
Lehman Brothers today than they had a year
ago when it happened, and I think that's irresponsible.
So let's see.
I see a couple of people.
Why don't we take a couple of more questions.
And I'm happy to -- there are more online
you want to do? Okay.
Q Okay. This is another popular one.
"Does the Fed now believe it's responsible
to pop bubbles? If so, how does it intend
to trade that off with other two responsibilities:
To keep inflation down and the economy stable?
Serving three masters is harder than serving
two.”
David Wessel: Yeah, but life's hard, right?
So, it's a really good question.
So the conventional wisdom was that the Fed
should not pop bubbles.
What that means is that, if the Fed is sitting
around like you and me might sit around.
We could all agree that stock prices have
gone up too far.
Housing prices have gone up too far.
The conventional wisdom is the Fed should
not raise interest rates to try and bring
down those prices of those assets.
And the thinking was that, "Well, first of
all, you might be popping a bubble that's
not really a bubble.
You only know after the fact if it's a bubble.
And you might actually do more harm than good
by popping a bubble.
And our job is to clean up the mess after
the bubble bursts.”
And this theory got a great test during the
tech stock bubble where they did very little.
You may remember Greenspan made that famous
speech about "Irrational Exuberance," which
everybody pretty much ignored.
And then, the bubble burst.
And they did things -- lowered interest rates
-- to keep the economy moving.
We had a recession, but it was a weak one.
And so, there was a lot of applause among
the economists that this was the right view.
And Bernanke was a subscriber to that view.
But if you ask Bernanke now what he thinks,
he says, "We have to rethink that thing."
Because we have just seen how much damage
can be done to an economy.
I mean, this is the worst recession we've
had since the Great Depression itself.
We have seen how much damage can be done to
an economy when the bubble bursts.
So I think there is a kind of -- this kind
of shakes up the intellectual underpinnings
that influenced monetary policy in the past
and they are in the process of rethinking
this.
And I think that, at least for the near term,
they will give more thought to whether they
should prick an asset bubble they think is
happening because of this.
Q Should institutions that are "Too big to
fail" be allowed to exist?
David Wessel: Right. Well, I think I answered
that.
The answer is, "Probably not, but we haven't
found a way to do without these big institutions.”
So the question is, How do we build a system
that is more insulated against the damage
done when one of these big institutions fails?
Q What new regulations does the Fed want to
create to dissipate the moral hazard caused
by its support for large banks?
David Wessel: The Fed wants to A, make these
banks hold more capital so they're less profitable.
It's kind of a tax on size.
Secondly, they promise to be more vigilant
in the regulation and supervision, which I'm
sure they'll be for a few years until the
memories wear thin.
And thirdly, you may have seen in the papers
the other day, they're talking about ways
to tweak the compensation of the big banks
to create fewer incentives to take these risks.
And I felt one of the most interesting things
they were doing is, they say they're going
to take the 25 banks, and they're going to
put their compensation plans on the table.
And they're going to ask the question, If
one of the banks is being more generous or
has some kind of weird thing, why are you
an outlier?
It's kind of like what they do in major league
sports, to try and prevent the banks from
having a bidding war for talent.
So it's a good thing you're here and not going
to business school and going to work in finance.
We have time for one more?
>> One more.
David Wessel: No, let's take this gentleman
behind you.
Q Yeah. So for banks and lenders, increasing
capital requirements can kind of help them
to be more stable, but for something like
AIG where they sell insurance, right?
It's not clear what kind of capital they need.
It seems like it's much harder for something
like AIG that's buying risk rather than lending
money.
David Wessel: AIG is something that should
not have been allowed to exist.
The problem wasn't their insurance businesses.
The problem was this huge portfolio of bets
-- the casino they were running on the side
-- and they did not hold enough capital to
make good those risks, make those bets.
So the answer is, we know pretty much how
to regulate insurance companies and we have
guaranteed funds when insurance companies
fail, but if you're going to be an insurance
company, then if you're also going to be in
the business of running a financial casino
on the side, that you have to have substantial
capital to back that up if you're doing this
risky trading.
>> David, thank you very much.
>> [Clapping]
David Wessel: Thank you.